hey what's up y'all i'm kelly clarkson
and i am right that's right wearing an
eye patch because the doctor told me to
because
this eye thing keeps happening and i
can't wear makeup and if i take it off
it looks really weird and gross so
you're welcome
oddly enough it also happens to be
international talk like a pirate day
so that's a thing i totally knew about
uh so i'm going to celebrate by telling
you some pirate jokes
so why'd the pirate join a gym to
improve his
booty i actually like that
i could use some of those what do you
have to do to do that how do you make a
pirate furious
take away the p irate oh
i get it that's a dad joke if i've ever
heard one
okay okay how much did the pirate pay
for his piercings
a buccaneer that's dumb
that's not good why does it take pirates
so long to learn the alphabet
because they can't spend years at sea
[Music]
because they can't spend years at sea
get it
it's funny oh they can
i didn't get it i just kind of went with
it yeah okay
you should use that because they can
spend years at sea ah because they don't
get to the whole alphabet
why did the pirate go on vacation he
needed a little
argan art
but i'm into it i'll take that one
what's a pirate's favorite exercise
the plank that's a lie i hate that
position
my body always trembles ugh what's a
pirate's favorite part of a song
ah the hook i like that one
hey we'll be here all week
uh well i hope you like some seafaring
hearty jokes did you get it we have it's
more of this coming
for some more fun be sure to tune into
season two of the kelly clarkson show
i don't know what i'm sounding like
don't get marooned check your local
listings i'm done with the pirate jokes